Dead Space has a vast timeline that
spans 300 years of Terror across a
Trilogy of games a few spin-off titles a
handful of comic books and novels and a
pair of films too but how does it all
tie together well it's a bit all over
the place once you jump outside the main
Trilogy with the books extending the
history of the franchise back nearly
three centuries into the past and the
film slotting in alongside and around
the main events of the original dead
space and with a shiny new remake of
that original game Awakening this
dormant franchise what better time to
dive into the hellish Misadventures of
Isaac Clarke hey my name's Adam and this
is the complete Dead Space timeline
fully explained
foreign
kicks off in the year 2214 with the
prequel novel Dead Space martyr in a
nutshell Mata Chronicles the origins of
the original Dead Space namely that of
the mysterious alien marker first found
on Earth its horrifying effects on
Humanity the Church of unitology and
crucially the creation of the
nightmarish Necromorphs an Unholy new
hybrid species that human corpses morph
into after prolonged exposure to the
marker foreign
set on Earth it follows the original
martyr of unitology The Reluctant
Prophet Michael Altman who is part of a
military operation to uncover an alien
Market in the Gulf of Mexico the reason
why everyone is so fussed about the
marker except for its obvious mystery is
the chance to use it as a source of
energy you see the Earth is in Dire
Straits when it comes to Resource
supplies and the marker could be its
Golden Goose for solving the problem
anyways long story short it isn't all
hell breaks loose in the military base
and the original batch of necromorph's
maim and kill all than sundry Altman
himself goes missing at the end of the
book at the hands of an organization
called The Sovereign colonies which
later becomes the equally Shady Earth
gov but more on them later and I won't
say any more than that as the book is
actually really good and definitely
worth a read so make sure to check it
out you want like you know the
unabridged version of that story
now we venture 80 years into the future
for our next entry another prequel novel
by the name of Dead Space Catalyst while
it doesn't expand upon the law of the
Dead Space Universe in quite the same
way as martyr Catalyst details the
origins of the red markers which are
basically man-made replicas of the
original alien version that are built by
those sneaky buggers at The Sovereign
colonies and will crop up a fair few
times across this timeline suffice to
say the red markers are a hit and by hit
I mean absolutely devastating turning
everything in their wake into a hellish
nightmare of Limbs and tentacles
foreign
right now we jump forward a measly two
decades which in the span of this
timeline is like a drop in the ocean to
the year 2314 for the prologue of Dead
Space 3. welcome to Tau volantis one of
the most hostile environments in a
franchise that's built on hostile
environments it's on this Backwater
hellscape that The Sovereign colonies
have Unearthed a new alien species at a
dig site in the bowels of the planet
only what they've actually discovered is
another bloody marker which promptly
sends everyone and everything a little
bit mad and that's the pretty picture
that's painted in the lead-up to the
prologue where we join private Kaufman
on his mission to rescue an alien codex
from a down ship he succeeds by the skin
of his teeth only to be murdered by his
own General who deletes all the
information on the Codex which turns out
to be Research into the markers before
promptly killing himself and with all
this Research into one of the Galaxy's
leading energy sources wiped out the
Sovereign Colony starts to collapse as
an organization which paves the way for
the aforementioned Earth gov to fill in
the power vacuum
[Music]
right here we go we jump forward a cool
200 odd years into the few ER to the
year of our Unholy Lord 2508 where a
whopping four entries on our timeline
take place kicking off with the tie-in
comic book to the original Dead Space
game the tie-in comic launched in the
lead-up to the release of the original
dead space back in 2008 and presented a
pretty heady cocktail of law before the
franchise had even kicked off taking
place on the planet of Ages 7 the Dead
Space Comics tell the story of the
calamitous tragedies that happened on
the planet's surface as a result of the
discovery of one of those pesky red
markers it turns out that earthgov has
shipped these man-made markers all over
the known universe and what just so
happens to be discovered at ages seven
on top of that in the years since Dead
Space Mata unitology has become the
foremost human religion in the Galaxy a
fact that would surely piss the
so-called Creator Michael Altman
write-off and the unitologists have gone
looking for the markers so they can see
out their weird culty plans of unity or
something and so ages 7 effectively
becomes Ground Zero for some seriously
weird stuff foreign
starts turning the local colonists
absolutely insane and long story short
this is exactly what happens on ages 7
in the lead-up to the original Dead
Space
[Music]
the animated film Dead Space downfall is
next on our timeline and takes the Baton
over nicely from the comics detailing
how the nightmare on ages 7 spread to
the orbiting USG ishimura a planet
cracking spaceship basically did you
ever wonder who wrote that iconic cut
off the limbs message from the original
Dead Space well here's your answer sort
of with ages 7 absolutely Fubar A Lone
Survivor attempts to make it back to the
ishimura with the body of his recently
deceased partner only he's not alone
asides of being a slightly derivative
Uber gory iteration of the original
alien downfall neatly slides into the
story of the original Dead Space which
launched just before the film was
released this extends to showing the
details of a few scenes that you hear
play out as audio logs found in the main
campaign of Dead Space including the
murder of the ishimura's captain and the
subsequent imprisonment of the chief
doctor
kill them dog
you all saw it he killed the captain
after the inevitable Carnage comes to
fruition the film slots into the opening
of Dead Space showing the main
protagonist's Chief security officer
Alyssa Vincent sending the SOS Beacon
that kick-starts the events of the first
game in the franchise before she blows a
horde of Necromorphs and herself out of
the goddamn airlock
but wait not content with giving us just
two prequels to the original Dead Space
game Electronic Arts thought it best to
give us another perspective with the Wii
shooter Dead Space extraction the game
kicks off at the ages 7 marker digsite
where an engineer Intoxicated by the
effects of the marker kills a whole load
of colonists he's out of his mind
Sterling
the story then jumps ahead to follow the
exploits of Detective Nathan McNeil and
his security officer Gabe Weller and
lexine Murdoch the girlfriend of the
aforementioned colonist killer the crew
managed to survive the chaos in ages 7
only to board the orbiting ishimura in a
situation that is literally the
dictionary definition of out the frying
pan and into the fire on their travels
they bump into the ishimura's senior
medical officer Nicole Brennan someone
who will come to know quite well as
series protagonist Isaac Clarke's
girlfriend after surviving necromorph's
left right and Center artrio eventually
make it to an escape shuttle and just in
the nick of time as they're escaping
they intercept a transmission from the
USG kelian the rescue ship dispatched to
investigate the SOS signal aboard the
ishimura lexin is unable to hail the
kelian and warn them of the dangers
aboard the planet cracker and that leads
us right into
okay after the chaos and downfall of
Ages seven we finally reached the very
first game the franchise also set in the
disastrous year of 2508. Dead Space
kicks off with the crew of the kelian
arriving to investigate an SOS signal
from the ishimura that's hovering over
the aforementioned hellscape of Ages 7.
when our Doom team lands aboard the
ishimura there's a docking malfunction
and the kelian is badly damaged forcing
our Rescue Team deeper into the bowels
of the seemingly abandoned ishimura and
less than 15 minutes into the game we
are reintroduce the welcome Hospitality
of the Necromorphs who slaught a pair of
hapless red shirt corporals and split
the rescue team up
foreign
hero the Dead Space franchise is forced
to find a weapon as we'll come to learn
across this timeline he's a resourceful
lad and repurposes a plasma cutter into
his vicious weapon of choice it's a
handy little Blaster too as it turns out
that the best way to down a Necromorph
is horrifyingly spelled out in blood on
a nearby wall and so we get into the
meat of dead space's survival narrative
Isaac's quest to re-team up with his
colleague Zach Hammond and Kendra
Daniels while dodging bloodthirsty Space
Zombies and fixing a spaceship that
wants to murder him at every possible
Avenue dotted around this nightmarish
Dark Ride are a handful of audio logs
that help fill in the backstory a
backstory that I've actually already
regaled but back in 2008 you had none of
that these handy little logs decode much
of the mystery of the Necromorphs the
cult-like Church of unitology and the
bizarre red marker as Isaac makes his
way around the ishimura Via very handy
rail network he uncovers more of the
mystery behind what happened aboard the
spaceship and its connections to the red
marker and Aegis 7 he also bumps into
some right Romans Chief among them a lad
called chalice Mercer and with that
first name like chalice you just know
he's a bad egg they're already
you see chalice has gone full religious
salad one of the many nasty side effects
of prolonged exposure to the marker are
the known side effects of exposure to
the marker include migraines dementia
suicide and turning into a hell's one
after death oh and the Bittersweet
horror of seeing long dead loved ones
which sadly plagues poor Isaac one of
the main reasons Isaac has long for this
ride is an SOS message from his
girlfriend Nicole and while aboard the
ishimura Isaac begins to have visions of
Nicole that make no sense and the reason
why they make no sense is yeah Nicole is
dead this bombshell is dropped in Isaac
by his crewmate Kendra Daniels who kill
surprise is the actual Chief antagonist
of Dead Space well aside from these bad
lads
turns out that Kendra is here on
government orders to retrieve the red
marker and has been trying to sabotage
the rescue mission all along this
nightmare all comes to a head down on
ages 7 where a giant freaking Necromorph
known as the hive mind has been
festering away after a tussle for
control of the marker between Isaac and
Kendra Kendra is killed by the hive mind
only for Isaac to shoot its weak points
for massive damage and you know death
Isaac escapes ages 7 aboard a shuttle
and as he drifts off into the relative
safety of deep space there's time for
one last jump scare courtesy of his
recently deceased girlfriend
foreign
[Music]
next up on the timeline is the animated
movie Dead Space aftermath which if you
hadn't already guessed takes place in
the destructive aftermath of Isaac
Clarke's Misadventures on the shimura a
crew aboard the usgo Bannon are tasked
with stabilizing the planet of Ages 7
which has become something of a powder
cake waiting to explode since isaaclass
left and as you can imagine things do
not go well
the tragedy of the O'Bannon is told
through flashbacks from four survivors
one of which is a science officer called
Dr Nolan Strauss who will come to know a
little better in Dead Space 2. long
story short the crew discover A Shard of
the red marker from the original Dead
Space which sends those who come into
contact a little bit loopy
after experimenting with The Shard
stross triggers another Necromorph Feast
which kills pretty much everyone
's with straws being carted off to the
sprawl a giant Metropolis on the Saturn
moon of Titan where he becomes cell
mates with our pal Isaac Clarke a fellow
marker Survivor who's also fallen into
the greedy hands of earthgov earthgov's
plan for them to build a brand new
marker as that's gone so well the last
couple of times
thank you
[Music]
the comic book Dead Space Salvage takes
place next on the timeline and it
Chronicles the efforts to find the
whereabouts of the ishimura which is
drifting somewhere in deep space to sum
it all up a host of different Salvage
Crews find the ishimura before
succumbing to the devastating effects of
our Necromorph battles A Lone Survivor
escapes the bloodbath and is this lucky
lad that informs earthgarve of the
location of the ishimura laying the path
for its reappearance in Dead Space 2.
but I'm very much getting ahead of
myself again
[Music]
now we jump forward to the year 2511
where the events of Dead Space 2 take
place on Titan the site of a brand new
marker but before we can jump into that
game there are a couple of prequels that
help set the scene the first
chronologically is the Dead Space mobile
game which Chronicles how the sprawl
became infested with Necromorphs you
play as Vandal a newly initiated member
of the Church of unitology who's being
Guided by the soothing voice of Tyler
radikoff only Tyler is the bad kind of
unitologist not that there's really a
good kind but you know what I mean and
he tricks Vandal into unleashing the
Necromorph hordes from the moon's mining
sector into its public sector
kickstarting the events of Dead Space 2.
Vandal manages to limit some of the
damage but they succumb to their wounds
in the game's conclusion which is also a
nice little homage to the original
Metroid when Vandal is revealed to be a
woman called Carrie Norton R.I.P Carrie
we hardly knew you
which leads us into our second prequel
the puzzle game Dead Space ignition
which takes us right up to the very
start of Dead Space 2. ignition follows
a pair of technicians Franco de Lyle and
Sarah Anderson as they venture out into
the sprawl to fix well everything in the
hours leading up to the Necromorph
Attack on Titan to be honest ignition
doesn't really add much narrative meat
to the bones of the Dead Space timeline
but there are a few things worth
mentioning Chief among them is that
Franco has an ulterior motive which is
revealed at the game's conclusion when
he sacrifices Sarah for his mission
what's his mission you may ask well it
turns out that Franco is actually a
sneaky unitologist as well and he's been
tasked by his Superior Diana leguan to
break a certain Isaac Clarke out of
custody the why behind that mission is
unveiled in Dead Space 2 which kicks off
literally seconds after the close of
ignition you're a free man
foreign
Dead Space 2 sees Isaac wake up from his
nightmare in a straight jacket and a
mighty sense of deja vu he's woken up by
Franco who is not long for this world
you're in terrible terrible
yep five minutes in and the protagonist
of the last game is necromorphada
leaving Isaac to fight his way through
another space zombie attack he's guided
for the first third of the game by the
voice of the aforementioned Diana who
nearly tricks Isaac into helping the
unitologist sabotage plan you see Isaac
has been busy in the three years since
we last saw him not that he remembers
any of it at all hence all his confusion
at the hellscape happening around him he
learns from Diana that another marker
has been built and by his hands no less
turns out he has been held captive for
the last three years by earthgov and for
one of a better word harvested by the
corrupt bureau bastards to build another
marker Diana and the unitologist want
Isaac the marker and all the research
for themselves but that plan is nipped
in the bud right away by the timely
intervention of an earth guard Dropship
that kills Diana and her cronies
Isaac ever the Survivor lives to see
another day and he teams up with a pilot
called Ellie and our old pal the good
doctor Nolan Strauss to venture across
the sprawl to destroy the new market and
put an end to this madness once of rule
along the way he encounters a couple of
ghosts from his past namely his long
dead girlfriend Nicole who haunts him
around every corner but also the hust
out remains of the USG ishimura which
Isaac has to revisit on his travels
Isaac eventually makes it to the marker
which is
um way bigger this time just in time for
a little something called convergence
some hoo-ha that the cult-like
unitologists have been banging on about
for forever after some trauma-inducing
eye surgery to unlock his mind Isaac is
ready for the festivities and he
celebrates by destroying anything and
everything in his path on the way to the
marker including the marker he does this
by getting pulled into his own mind by
his dead girlfriend and just shooting
her repeatedly until she goes away
handily this rids all traces of the
marker from his brain and helpfully
destroys the marker to boot and as the
Titan base starts blowing up around him
Isaac consigns himself to a cold lonely
death in the void of space but as the
credits start to roll in this downbeat
ending Ellie turns up in the nick of
time to rescue him and with that the
game ends with the cheekiest of all nods
to that Infamous jump scare from the
first game
what
okay second currently with Dead Space 2
is its story DLC pack severed which sees
our old friends Gabe Weller and Lexi
Murdoch return to the fold they're also
doing their best to survive the
Necromorph infestation aboard the Titan
sprawl and that's no mean feat for
lexine as she's pregnant with Gabe's
baby Gaby after navigating murderous
Necromorphs and bureaucrats alike game
eventually makes it a lexine only to
have to sacrifice himself for her and
his unborn child when he has to stay
behind a disengage the airlock
restricting their escape in the process
his leg gets blown off by a grenade
hence the title seven I guess and with
his last act in life he opens the
airlock to allow lexine to escape before
dying from his wounds and getting sucked
out into the cold dark of space this
franchise really likes killing off its
spin-offs protagonists
right we're finally on the home stretch
with the prequel comic to Dead Space 3
titled Liberation this Titan comic
largely sets up the chess pieces for the
upcoming Trilogy conclusion but is
noticeable for introducing nobody's
favorite Co-op partner John Carver The
Cliff Notes version of the comic because
you should go and read it yourself is
all around unitologist bad egg Jacob
danik kills Carver's wife and son after
they discover information regarding the
Sovereign colonies Research into markers
with this research back in the wild it
kicks off a race for knowledge on the
markers which leads our pilot friend
Ellie Langford on a quest to tell
volantis and our culty enemy danik on a
crusade to cleanse Humanity with his Old
Testament rendition of unitology
foreign
ly get to the conclusion of this
nightmarish franchise Dead Space 3 which
really Chucks everything into the mix to
see what happens what actually happens
save the prologue which we've already
covered is well more of the same but
bigger you see Dead Space 3 takes us to
the supposed marker home world of Tau
volantis a frozen Backwater of a planet
where the Sovereign colonies have been
up to some shady stuff but I'm getting
ahead of myself again this Trilogy
closer kicks off in 2514 roughly three
years after the events of dead space 2.
in that time Isaac has tried to get back
to a normal life and by normal I mean
sulking in his grotty looking apartment
and alienating himself from his
ex-girlfriend his savior from the last
game Ellie Langford but that sulking
doesn't last long as he's thrust back
into action by a pair of Earth gov
soldiers supposedly the last who are
trying to get out of Dodge before
they're killed by the local Army of
crazy unitologist led by the
aforementioned bad guy Jacob dannick
Isaac Clarke just the man I was looking
for one of of these soldiers is our new
mate Sergeant John Carver and the other
is Ellie's new bow Captain Robert Norton
they enlist Isaac to help them find
Ellie who's gone missing on a mission to
find the marker signal Source at Tao
volantis after they escaped the
unitologist the trio hot foot it across
the Galaxy and rescue Ellie and her team
within the orbit of Tau volantis I knew
you were too stubborn to die and with
their own ship seriously damaged This
ragtag Crew managed to scavenge up a new
space-worthy ship but instead of getting
the hell out of there they crash learn
their new ride on the surface of
talvalantis believing it to be the
origin of the markers and thus the place
where they can destroy it all this plan
does not go well for them you see tau
volantis is not the marker Homeworld
it's the location of a previous marker
convergence that happened to an ancient
alien race who built a machine to freeze
the entire planet and put a stop to the
marker Madness and this is what Isaac
Carver and Ellie discover as they
explore the freezing hell of the
planet's surface to add insult to injury
Norton the slimy bastard betrays the
crew and cool was in danic and his
unitologists in exchange for his own
safety which doesn't end well for Norton
or danik
after rebuild rebuilding an alien codex
the key to the machine keeping
everything on Ice Isaac and Carver delve
deep into the alien City to confront the
source of all this madness which turns
out to be a giant freaking Necromorph
Moon after a desperate battle with the
moon Isaac and Carver sacrifice
themselves to destroy the lunar
monstrosity which it turns out is
broadcasting in the Necromorph bad vibes
galaxy-wide these knights in shining
space armor send Ellie off to safety in
a shuttle blow the moon up and set the
alien machine to reject convergence not
sure why the aliens didn't do that in
the first place and that kills the
marker signal with Isaac and Carver
supposedly dead Ellie flies off home
with her mission to destroy the signal
complete I think
you did it only they're not dead
in the DLC expansion the pair wake up
back on the surface of Tau volantis
seemingly very much alive and in good
health except for the crippling
migraines that Harbor ominous Visions
brushing those aside the pair attempt to
escape the barren Wasteland and bump
right into a load of unitologists also
trying to escape long story short they
managed to salvage a ship and escape to
the orbiting terranova where they
encounter more of the unitologist cult
who they promptly murder with Isaac
quickly losing his mind to weird
tentacle Visions he turns on his Co-op
partner and after their subsequent fight
they realize that there are actually
plenty of Necromorph moons still
knocking about and they're all heading
right for Earth the pair hightail it
back to Earth to warn Humanity but when
they get there they're too late and that
disastrous bombshell is where we leave
the Dead Space franchise as Isaac and
Carver watch on as the Necromorph moons
start to destroy their home planet
or so we think for all we know this
whole story DLC pack could all be a
dream
[Music]
and that guys is the Dead Space timeline
fully explained I hope you enjoyed my
little mooch through this mad franchise
if you did make sure to check out my
other timelines on God of War The Last
of Us or metroid thanks for watching
guys I'll see you next time
[Music]